PROFESSOR: Hi, welcome
back to recitation.
Today we are going to talk
about an infinite series
and discuss its convergence.
So in particular I have
this infinite series.
The sum from n
equals 1 to infinity
of 1 divided by the
product n times n plus 1.
So what I'd like you
to do is to compute
a few terms of the series,
compute a few partial sums,
and use that to get
a sense for what
you think the series is doing.
Is it converging?
Is it diverging?
If it's converging,
can you figure out
what value it's converging to?
So why don't you
pause the video,
take some time to try that out,
see what you get, come back
and we can do it together.
So this is a nice series.
It has terms that
are easy to compute.
And I've taken the liberty
of computing a few of them
in advance, and I've
put them up over here.
So for n from 1 to 5, the
terms that we're adding up
are 1 over n times n plus 1.
So that's when n
equals 1, that's
1 over 1 times 2, which is 1/2.
When it is 2, it's 1 over
2 times 3, which is 1/6.
Then we've got 1/12,
1/20, 1/30, and so on.
So those are the
things we're adding up.
And then the partial sums,
the nth partial sums.
Well, the first one is just
the first term, which is 1/2.
The second one, we take the
first term and the second term
and we add them together.
So 1/2 plus 1/6 is 2/3.
The third one, we take
the first three terms
and add them together
and that gives us 3/4.
And OK, so I computed the first
five partial sums here as well.
Now, if you look
at this column-- so
remember that the limit, that
the value of an infinite series
is defined to be the
limit of its partial sums.
So if we want to know,
what is the value
of this infinite series
that we started with,
does it converge,
does it diverge,
what we have to do
to figure that out
is we have to take
its partial sums
and we have to
compute their limit.
And if we-- if their
limit doesn't exist,
then it diverges.
If their limit does exist,
then the sum of the series
is equal to what that
value of that limit is.
And if you look at
these terms here,
you'll see that they, there's
a little bit of a pattern
here, right?
So these, this is 1/2,
2/3, 3/4, 4/5, 5/6.
That's a pretty nice
sequence of numbers.
It's, you know, we could
probably guess at this point
that the next one is going
to be 6/7 then 7/8 and so on.
So that would be a guess.
One way we can
actually prove this
is, so we have this guess
that-- let me write it down.
Guess is that S_n is
equal to n over n plus 1.
Now if you wanted to confirm
this guess, what you'd
have to do is you have
to just figure out
how could you prove that.
Well, one thing
you can do is you
can say, well, S n
plus 1 is equal to S_n
plus the next term, right?
So in our case, S n
plus 1 is equal to S_n
plus the next term, the n plus
first term, which in our case
is 1 over n plus
1 times n plus 2.
So, all right, so
that's not maybe obvious
what to do with this, but
you could split this up,
really you can split it
up by partial fractions.
And you can write this as say
S_n plus-- so if you split this
up by partial fractions,
what you'll get
is that it's exactly equal
to 1 over n plus 1 minus 1
over n plus 2.
And from here it's
easy to see that, well,
if S_n is equal to
n over n plus 1,
then this will be
equal to 1 minus 1
over n plus 2, which is
n plus 1 over n plus 2.
And so using the process known
as mathematical induction,
you have that it follows
for all values of n.
So because of this nice
expression for the term,
it's easy to see that this
pattern will continue forever.
OK, and so that, you
know, that's just
a sketch of how you
would prove this.
Now once you've
proven this, it's
easy to see that the-- once
you know that this is true,
it's easy to see what
this limit is, right?
As n goes to infinity,
this just approaches
1 and that means
the series converges
and the limit of
the series is 1.
So here we have a nice example
of a series that converges
and where it actually
is possible to compute
the limit of this series.
This isn't possible for
most, for all series
or even for most series.
Even ones with
fairly nice terms,
it's often very difficult to
figure out what their limit is,
but in this case
it's not hard to do
and we have precisely that
the value of the series is 1.
So I'll end there.